das spiel hatte bei steam so unglaublich
wenige download das ist jetzt nicht
deren ernst hallo mein name ist luca und
wir spielen heute ein zombie-spiel
dieses spiel heißt antennen und ich bin
auf dieser map hier
die grafik ist echt scheiße ich hab die
grafik jetzt einmal freigestellt und sie
ist immer noch recht scheiße das ganze
soll so ein bisschen wie daisy sein
denke ich mal
aber rein gar nicht so aus ich habe
unten links die werte angezeigt wie
lange ich ohne wasser kann und das unten
geht jetzt gerade runter weil ich glaube
ich gerade spüren
er ist eine person oh mein gott ich
glaube die person mag uns nicht
besonders aber wir haben zwei fäuste mit
denen wir glaube ich wir haben bogen ich
versuche jetzt mal diesen zombie hier
vorne
scheiße
was mache ich denn jetzt lasst mich in
ruhe das dann übrigens ich ein scheiß
den ich habe jetzt wieder meine hände
ausgewählt und kann jetzt ein zombie
hier
das spielt sich unglaublich cool aus
einer sicherlich gesagt keine lust der
sie zocken weil mir das alles zu
realistisch ist aber dass jetzt halt
einfach so total simpel ich habe einfach
ich kann
von links nach rechts schauen ich habe
eigentlich gar nicht gedacht das ganze
hier als serie zu machen weil ich das
spiel einfach bei steam gefunden hat und
ich nach new york führt to play dann
nehme ich das doch was ist das denn
lexware west hab ich keine weste
angezogen oh mein gott ich sehe
unfassbar cool aus ich hab mir dann halt
einfach mal runtergeladen und nimmer
angeschaut und dachte dann solo fast gar
nicht das spiel sehr cool aus und dann
habe ich mir angeschaut dachte ich oh
das kann ich ja eigentlich echt mal
zocken aber es sieht jetzt wirklich so
aus als wenn man hier mit wirklich eine
serie machen könnte ich muss mich wohl
selber noch ein bisschen hier rein
finden weil es gibt doch noch crafting
und skills und in form mein gott ist die
map wirklich so riesig obwohl diese
grafik einfach so unglaublich scheiße
ist habe ich immer angst dass hier noch
irgendwie zombies herumlaufen können und
wir haben mein gott sie haben sogar in
kitchener ich hab jetzt tatsächlich
schon meinen inventar so ein bisschen
aufgefüllt und zwar seht ihr schon dass
ich hier beispielsweise chips habe ich
habe hier eine karotte ich habe respekt
und ich hab jetzt mittlerweile auch von
messer womit ich einfach mal das ist
nicht wahr ach du heilige scheiße
ich bin in dem traktor freuen ich wollte
eigentlich nur eine party von hochladen
aber dieses spiels unglaublich cool bin
ich eigentlich der einzige der da spielt
das spiel hatte bei steam so unglaublich
wenige download das ist jetzt nicht
deren ernst diese blöden pizza dahinten
mein traktor kaputt gemacht haben werde
ich jetzt meinen mesz liegt wenn wir
sein denn hier ihr werdet dafür bezahlen
das ist jetzt nicht wahr
die haben ein traktor kaputt gemacht und
sich dabei selbst getötet
deren ernst der traktor war quasi meine
einzige möglichkeit so ein bisschen
schneller von a nach b zu kommen und
jetzt ist er einfach kaputt neros august
zusammen zu warten ich habe ich gedacht
dass es ein kleines spiel könnt ihr mal
kurz anzocken vielleicht ein bisschen
zombies töten vielleicht paar mal
sterben besiegen und dann habe ich ein
tolles video hier werden vor produziert
aber es ist echt cool und sie
tatsächlich sehr umfangreich aus wenn
ihr also bock habt dass sich eventuell
noch einen zweiten teil davon hochladen
oder das ganze als serie lebt da hinten
wieder jemand oder das ganze halt als
serie mal anfangen und daraus wie
nintendo knapp und hochladen dann gibt
doch einfach an einen daumen oo und ich
töte jetzt noch so ein paar davon ist
die cloud war mein gott
ich habe einen kurs ich war übrigens
auch schon mal quad fahren in wales das
ist jetzt allerdings ein komplett
anderes video aber das war mein vater
ist ein zombie ich war in wales quad
fahren das video verlinkt ich euch hier
das war mit max da waren wir waren in
wales und waren quad fahren und es war
sehr cool also checkt das video aus ich
möchte auch gern mal wissen ob ich da
hin in diesem typen jetzt einfach mal um
fahren kann
das ist zwar riesig ich muss unbedingt
leben regenerieren ich glaube wir müssen
das spiel einfach mal ein bisschen mehr
zocken noch und ihr müsst mir noch ein
paar tipps dazu in die kommentare
schreiben oder ihr ladet euch selbst mal
ohne das ganze ist kein place mit ich
fand ich denke ehrlich gesagt nicht dass
das ganze hinspiel ist was man über zwei
monate hinweg zocken kann aber es ist
auf jeden fall recht cool und ich würde
gerne öfter hochladen wenn ihr das also
auch wollt dann könnt ihr mir einfach
mal daumen hoch da lassen das zeigte mir
dadurch dann quasi ab jetzt haben wollte
doch was ist das denn
ja und ich brauche noch weitere tipps
wie ich meine gesundheit auffüllen kann
weil ich habe jetzt ja gar kein held
package oder irgend so ein schwachsinn
hiermit und ich glaube wir noch einen
zombie kommen sollte bin ich ganz schön
am arsch das ganze bild ist jetzt gerade
halt so ein bisschen grau könig weil ich
halt nicht mehr durch gegeben habe aber
ich setze jetzt einfach mal auf mein
quad files hier noch ein bisschen weiter
ein quartett auch noch 23 zustand und
dann lade ich einfach die nächsten paar
tage mal zweiten part hoch weil ich
denke ihr wollt auf und ihr freut euch
immer wenn ich eine neue serie anfange
und da spielen wir dann hier weiter des
werden
ende
wir müssen noch einen drauf machen im
heutigen türchen 16 meine damen und
herren haben wir drin enthalten einen
einen hund wir haben fluffy im heutigen
dings enthalten ist der neue hund
hierfür arien läuft ja immer ganz gern
mit handtaschen rum und jetzt hat sie
halt einen schlaffi in der handtasche
ende vom video